all right ready for this musical intro
oh yeah what do you got has he written
something for us what do you got
[Music]
I like the progression something about
space aliens I'm intrigued
ah just music I said that I thought
that'd be I thought he had some lyrics
yeah
digital podcast man I don't know why I'm
talking with a Jamaican here we are here
we go
what are you Hanks what's going on with
you what a reference
yo I was born in Jamaica okay okay
there had to be yeah look had to get it
in quick it's episode 179 it's been a
long strange trip I don't know how we
got here but here we are red and I have
the same shirt on gosh look at that go
to Digital Dot score yeah and of course
well you missed it if you're going now
you missed it oh yeah good point no no
store for you right no store for you we
have Ren today hello Ren hi hi Ron hi
Jordan Jordan Allen hi God damn it hi
Matt hi Jordan we have Matthew Karen's
hi Matt you Karen
so um guys before we get into the UFO
stuff because that's what we're gonna
Jump Right In yeah yeah yeah yeah I've
got one quick one quick thing
um I need to let the world know
uh today you got it in country western
music uh Coulter wall released a new
record and I bought it and uh you don't
have to buy it on vinyl but uh here it
is you did though do you put that in
like a special player
yeah it actually it goes in a CD player
that's of an enlar you know those three
track or five track CD players you put
it on there oh okay that makes more
sense no I get it I like that article I
actually really like his collab with
Chet Hanks yeah he does do a good one of
his best yeah
confusion yeah it's really special yeah
man awesome how dare you how dare you
tarnish the good name of Chad thanks I'm
sorry
listeners please do count the amount of
Chet Hank's references because uh we're
really trying to get the numbers up
trying to bring him back those numbers
up guys he really you know I really
think he has something to contribute so
he does he does yeah also can I just
give a shout out to Matt real quick for
bringing us these beers today I mean
they're cool looking just this is
legitimately one of my top three
favorite beers of all time and I have
not been able to find it for months well
buddy it's one of mine too and uh I know
where to find the good stuff so those of
you listening is called dig my Earth and
it's got this like crazy Fox thing it's
from breweries West Brewery West Brewery
spelled with German words yeah I always
just know it's the fox beer yeah
oh they're all their Brewers are quite
good but yeah so uh in case you're not a
a beer fan let's move on yeah yeah
what's been happening okay I'm glad I
could give you that gift we we not only
did we release a debunking we then did
this whole thing where we slipped a
secret UFO video into the debunking
episode and Sam and Nico react to it and
then we did a crew cuts episode about
that and then
you had the audacity to make another UFO
video to try to fool the internet so
yeah I don't I don't know I don't know
what's gotten into YouTube but I think
you need to explain yourselves yeah I
love this story so yeah honestly started
months ago for the record yeah no four
months five months ago now uh this
started five months ago this whole Saga
and it's so long and involved that
um you know there's what's on The
Cutting Room floor right now what didn't
make the final edit of this latest crew
video uh is enough to fill a podcast
which is why we're here today
that video just dropped on Corridor
today yeah it's going up on YouTube
tomorrow so I haven't even seen this
final video yet right yeah so the world
will you haven't seen it um not the
final like upload right all right yeah
so but by the time this podcast is out
it'll be out there but um you know the
it was uh it was a whole journey to get
the post uh of this second video like so
that if we're going all the way back you
know can I just this started as a thing
called project Maple Leaf yeah yes oh my
gosh oh
tons of ideas we have to we have a new
video coming out every week so we always
have like these brainstorming sessions
and one of the ideas was like What if we
could fool the internet with a fake UFO
video yeah and I was like oh let's do it
as a challenge and Matt was like so
excited he did the whole challenge
before we even started recording
anything yeah we finished it I was amped
to do it man because it was it was such
an interesting idea and I just I there's
something like immediately that I saw in
my head like a game plan that started
formulating and I was like I can just do
it real quick because it's like it's not
like that VFX are hard yeah that's why
it took you to do the actual effects
like an hour maybe okay you know total
um
yeah yeah exactly because it was just
like not it's just a dot it was just a
DOT that needed to move across the frame
uh and really like I just took a step
back and I just looked watched a bunch
of UFO videos on uh r slash UFO okay uh
the subreddit the main subreddit of uh
the UF
it's not even the same thing yeah it has
nothing to do with UFOs yeah it's
actually yeah
hi there yeah what what's that it's not
slash uaps no just yeah yeah because you
know the world knows understands them as
UFOs uh you know you can you can mix and
match the names the government can try
to change the name of it all day yeah
yeah
you know get us to forget about it but
we all know the truth is out there yeah
it ain't my UFO right exactly I'm a UFO
guy yeah uh so yeah I just kind of
watched a bunch of videos and the ones
that were the most trending the most
popular
um and also uh had a bunch of people in
the comments uh buying it you know
believing it um whether it's real
footage or not uh I just kind of wanted
to go like what's what's like the best
angle goal for this and honestly like
the big thing was the perspective like
the the plate the unique yeah the unique
angle to uh get people to click on it
and watch it um so you know that that
really came from having access to uh
pilot footage like cockpit footage in a
plane
um that I already had and knew that I
could get uh so it was just it was
something where it was really easy for
me to access it get a bunch of different
options for footage because my stepdad
is a pilot if you didn't know said that
many times but now you know
um so now I have this footage and I'm
like okay what's the best angle boom I
got it yeah uh what's what uh should I
do for the VFX basically just very
simply animate a DOT flying across the
frame from right to left stopping
abruptly and then changing direction and
that that's the thing that really will
uh cement this is not like a phenomenon
that makes sense
um and there's there's levels to it too
with you know first of all all inside a
cockpit is one of the most unique
perspectives I've ever seen as soon as I
heard you were doing that I knew it was
going to be good immediately oh yeah so
did you already have the footage in your
back pocket or did you specifically ask
your stepbat your stepdad to get this
footage yeah so well he because I knew
that he was of course he's a pilot and
he's been flying for a really long time
so I knew that he would just like and he
loves his iPhone he loves moment on the
thing so I figured that he would have
footage already so I did just ask him do
you have anything that already that you
can just send me and he said yeah I'll
send you this this and this and you for
for him really like what he's filming is
just passing planes he just wants to
film planes going by and he thinks
they're cool I do that too yeah anytime
I'm in an airplane and I look at and I
see another airplane I'm like get my
phone out yeah exactly it's exactly in
that airplane doing the exact same thing
I hope so I wish they could just reverse
angle they just wave at each other
online that you can just upload your
plane footage yeah
see if we can connect the footage
triangulate the footage we should do
that that would be sick yeah that's
that's a crazy idea I want to think
about metadata anymore
yeah that's a lot of stuff that didn't
make the final video either it's just
like it's just the whole metadata
Journey but anyway oh really yeah
there's a lot we'll talk about all this
but there's a lot of stuff that doesn't
make the final challenge so you got the
clip the airplane clip yeah so I got the
airplane clip
um and the so obviously like you guys
didn't see a plane you know even though
so I just strategically like placed uh
the shot uh in a place that you couldn't
see another plane passing it was before
you actually saw the clip of the the
plane moving so I just used the the
everything before that right so yeah it
was just a clean sky that I could then
place an object in uh and I
strategically had the camera move so I
had I strategically like placed a moment
in there uh where the camera was moving
just for no reason but it looked like it
was tracking with the object right so
it's just sort of selling the the idea
that it's found footage right
um so yeah so from there we basically
take this video uh and I put it on the
subreddit right I just I post it right
you upload directly to Reddit yeah host
it anywhere else it's hosted on
reddit.com that's right yeah so it's on
reddit.com right and it like from there
takes off them like as soon as I put it
up it started getting views that was
crazy yeah didn't you put it up on like
a Friday afternoon yeah it was like an
hour before the day was over and you're
already like like as we're like getting
ready to like head out for the day it's
like oh it's getting musical it's like
oh wow this is really cool yeah well it
was and it was a thing that I was just
thinking I'll let it cook over the
weekend and hopefully on Monday it'll
get some traction or something and we're
just like the day's about to end and all
of us are just watching it like explode
comments people are buying it hundreds
of thousands of views and just like a
bunch of comments because you also made
it incredible
subtle like you made it almost too
subtle yeah it was hard to see and
that's I think common that I've been
meaning to bring up about the subtle the
subtleness of it yeah did you also
notice that there's like a bird in the
shot as well
of the of the the original one the
object passes and then it goes down yes
well right as it goes down
like there's another small black object
that like crosses remember slightly
higher than it is I don't know I think
that's actually a speck on the
windshield when it's moving is it I
believe so I I don't know if you did
that intentionally or no because when I
first watched it that's what I saw and I
and I was thinking did it cross the
frame and then go that way or look at
the imagination at play look at this is
the thing man
the subtlety makes the comments go nuts
yeah because like people are seeing all
kinds of stuff in the in the footage
right it's not just the the thing you
want them to see it's like all kinds of
other things because they're really you
know when you make them really look for
something it's like you can see all
kinds of your imagination runs wild at
that point there was that one comment I
mean this if you want to know if you
were subtle or not there's that one
comment that's like hey I can't see it
and someone posted a picture circling
two black dots and neither one was the
right one
have you heard of that psychology
experiment where they asked uh college
students to pick out how many times a
basketball was bounced between two
basketball teams you've probably heard
of this yeah yeah I know this one I love
this test and that they put two teams
one was in white jerseys one was in
black jerseys and they bounced the ball
back and forth a bunch of times and they
just had like a static shot
the passes yeah yeah and so they had
people come in and they said okay count
the number of passes between the teams
and so people would sit there for like
the 90 seconds or whatever that the the
clip was and they'd sit there and they'd
count them all and most people got it
right and then they'd go okay did you
notice the gorilla that came into the
street I've seen it and like hooted and
pounded its chest and then ran off
screen and half of the people didn't see
it yeah
I didn't see it either there's there's
one online that's like that it got you
two it got me too wow I was so surprised
going back and watching it again
something and when you watch the UFO
footage you're like looking for the
thing that's not supposed to be there I
want to believe yes so hard yeah that's
right yeah that's exactly right and
that's just good that experiment kind of
like goes right in line with that yeah
yeah for sure
um yeah yeah so so that's exactly it
it's because people were like paying
attention wanting to believe wanting to
see something you know um and then there
was actually something there so you know
you see this it's like actually a crazy
aerial phenomenon that doesn't really
make sense so uh that also got things
really moving but then people started
asking for the original files that's
right they did so what did you do but
and why did they ask for that because I
made a version of this video that was
screen capped from my iPhone so so that
I could zoom in pinch in and like like
really like get the thing uh clear right
that you can see something happening uh
in the frame
um but I didn't want it to seem like I
was an editor or had anything to do with
filmmaking and it does add that an
additional layer of separation
even though your Reddit account was
mobile films Pro but that's okay it
doesn't matter I didn't think that that
mattered I mean it matters now when we
did the second one but it just did it
wasn't like it wasn't super important
thing guys yeah that part that part
wasn't super important to me I I just
really like yeah at that point I was
just trying to do it fast and dirty and
I was super cocky about it too so you
know I just was like this is gonna work
this is totally gonna work I don't care
if the Reddit account has some holes in
it you know it's not a big deal for me
um and it people didn't really look at
it necessarily uh but they did want the
original file right and I was like I
could give it to him there you go I I
could give it to him because the thing
is like when you look at a file a video
file
um on the Windows uh you know operating
system it doesn't it shows you a certain
amount of metadata but it doesn't show
you everything
um I didn't know that I thought that the
amount of metadata that it's giving you
is everything that you need to know
about the file even you know when you
when you look into it there's nothing
else to say no no you're you're the
chances are your men are already dead
they know all the metadata yeah yeah and
that was my big mistake is I this is my
favorite part of the whole song by far
my huge mistake was that even though I I
tried to have some forethought into like
putting having the file on the desktop
in a folder that wasn't suspicious and
you know and naming the file uh an
iPhone you know naming convention and
all this stuff right uh but what
happened was they simply plugged the
file into a website called metadata to
go and could go metadata to go can
extract literally everything all the
stuff you need to go
an original file pass before the video
was exported from that's we're exported
too rather well as long as you name it
anything suspicious yeah right anything
suspicious yeah if you would have just
named it like that's uncle's footage
yeah
[__]
what was it mvi underscore it was Matt's
totally real UFO footage undeniable
evidence
clearly an after effects
link Destiny decord or digital yeah yeah
yeah the file path was like our Master
server starting location like Corridor
projects Corridor crew
UFO footage that's undeniable evidence
dot V1 dot AEP
the comments too
up in a comment on the Reddit thread
like when you first saw that like that
because that all happened off camera
like rather off camera from my eyes like
you weren't home yeah well no here this
is the this is the part that also didn't
make the final cut of this of the crew
video uh this detail I uh this night I
went on a date a first date with a girl
okay and I didn't find out what was
happening until I had gotten there and
we were like sitting down to eat and you
were flying high too old
this is gonna be a great date because
I'm gonna I'm so amped right now this is
gonna be awesome wait to tell this girl
about UFOs for like hours she's gonna
love it because girls love this stuff
yeah yeah and when they go on dates with
guys who go on about UFOs girls love
UFOs yeah and they love guys that are
super amped about tricking the internet
and thinking they're real so so yeah but
then so I sit down she goes to the
bathroom my check my phone because I'm
not gonna check my phone come on I'm
better than that but she goes to the
bathroom I check my phone okay and I see
this comment of a guy that doxed me just
outright put all of the metadata on in
the comments and I was like [__]
I and I was like I had to do something
quick I had to do something real quick
because I was like well if the other
guys are going to try to make UFO videos
like all their this is gonna I gotta
sell this whole thing I gotta just I
gotta burn the whole thing so I deleted
the entire post I had to immediately
even though it was all taken out which
one was that the neck the next week we
were all going to work on this video we
were
renders right and try to fool the
internet
but I not only burned myself I burned
the entire Corridor crew like that
like every they were burned the entirety
of project Maple Leaf yeah yeah this
this could have not been a video at all
with project Maple Leaf was not only to
create
the perfect UFO footage that would fool
the internet it was also to create the
perfect UFO footage that would fool Sam
and Nico in a UFO debunking episode yeah
what you guys may not know is again
project Maple Leaf has been has been in
existence for over a year yeah like over
a year yeah
it was a very underground thing I think
it was like Fenner was in the know I was
in a Christian
I was not in the net yeah no that's true
because I said I said this lasted like
four or five months but that's my
personal experience like previously
y'all had started talking about this a
year ago right and again yeah the
intention was to fool you guys we
weren't sure if you were going to be in
it you know so we needed it to be as
Hush Hush yeah no for sure created
Fenner created the Reddit name username
XXX files XXX yeah a year ago a year ago
right and and that was that was one of
the parts of it it was like okay we need
to start creating accounts so that when
we get to the point like they have Karma
and that's right wait why do we not use
that account for this then oh we did
okay okay
I've seen all the behind the scenes I
was there for a while for sure final
thing I can't wait that's all good
um you'll get we'll get there
um yeah so so uh where are we in the
story Jesus so this is metadata you have
been docked you burned into the account
and the comments were going that's host
oh there's a guy called Matt who works
at Corridor oh Madness
oh it wasn't
the crew video like the editing and I
also like directed the piece too so it
was like the I was like deep in the
Weeds on it in the last couple weeks um
I sent this I sent like the one of the
cuts one of the earlier cuts to some of
my friends that are like super critical
about [__]
um one of them is also like a history
professor and he told me that uh this
metadata thing like having blunders like
that there's something that happened
recently with Russia uh the Kremlin
released a bunch of like uh fake
propaganda videos and they got found out
because of the metadata same kind of
thing you know where they were they were
making uh ukrainians look bad uh with
with like you know doctor footage
footage of War of them like like
infiltrating some bases or something
like that I don't know the details of
this uh as much but yeah so so yeah yeah
War stuff um but tell me
yeah the Russian government I know it's
crazy the the Russian government
released propaganda footage yeah to
their people to try to school them for
something I believe they're also trying
to fool ukrainians as well they're
trying they're trying to spin the
narrative on them they're trying to fool
the world it's insane but like yeah so
anyway the metadata if not that metadata
got him caught there's the same kind of
thing where it was like it was linked to
an editing file like an edit like a
Premiere project or something like that
so yeah same kind of deal man so okay so
you're on this date she's gone to the
bathroom you've just found out that you
have to burn everything to the ground
down there do you wait until after
everybody down there yeah so right then
and there you're like yeah okay and I
was like well not talking about UFOs she
comes back and you're just covered in
yeah
all right so tell me more about this UFO
post you just made me you're like what
post yeah I don't know I don't know what
you're talking about yeah just just
change the subject what do you like to
do on the week what do you do yeah what
do you do do you work what do you cry
I like to cry and I think was it the
next night because there was a little
get-together at Peter's Place yeah and I
saw Matt there and I was frothing for
information I was so excited and I went
and I found him immediately I'm like
Matt what's the view count where's it at
and I've never seen a more broken man
it's all gone yeah man and then like
months pass because we're like well we
can't do this video now yeah I mean like
it's it's fresh in everyone's memory on
the subreddit and this is the subreddit
specifically that we're trying to fool
yeah it's the biggest Community it's
necessary to do it like this so that it
makes the most sense a couple months
went by things were dead the case had
gone cold and that's right and then and
then Nick
comes up with the idea
hey you know we already shot a lot of
that we could probably just do a couple
extra scenes and fill in the gaps and
release a new episode
uh like an episode just based on that
yeah based on the originals that whole
like story that we just told right and
then we we pitched that to you Matt and
you and Jordan said you know what let's
take it one step further yeah let's make
another one
um that's right do it again that's right
let's do it again let's try to take all
the stuff that we learned and make a
better video yeah uh that it will
actually work you know and I'm I'm you
know I one thing I would say about the
new approach is whose idea was the Tesla
cam so okay throw this out there that
was actually I believe you and Nick were
oh we were gonna do that for ours you
were gonna do that long ago yeah you
were originally gonna do it that's a
great idea the reason why I know this is
because in the original footage when I'm
when I'm going like check this out I'm
nailing it you know I'm like I'm
freaking like in there super cocky like
you know the Reddit post you guys are in
the background you and Nick talking
about your idea like we gotta do some
something that's like better you know
and you're like what if we get do Tesla
cams oh that is so funny right and so I
see that and I'm like I was about to
compliment it it is a good idea
it's a good bad cop bad cop and he's
already going that hard then I gotta go
yeah yeah it might have come from Nick
too I can't remember exactly but yeah I
mean that's the thing is the unique
perspective and when we started ours I
was a little bummed because the the
airplane cockpit was taken right and
that's like that's the Primo yeah that's
the ultimate a pilot filming a UFO is
like immediate credit because guys
Pilots know about the skies they know
they know about aircraft they do know
it's Flats
they can take it from unidentified to
identified that's right exactly that's
the big difference yeah so if a pilot
thinks something it's basically as good
as a doctor you know yeah yeah
doctor of Disguise
yeah the point is we thought that I
think moving forward to the Tesla angle
would be great because like having
having the ability to record immediately
something you just saw uh flying through
the sky uh that's what Tesla's did
there's an ability that's what Tesla
says
stuff going through the sky they can
find UFOs if you if you're ever trying
to catch a UFO you just honk your horn
yeah and you capture the last 10 minutes
of of uh footage you know it's always
rolling essentially hey man I had a
question about that quick question do
you does it record into the future as
well like once you honk it does it keep
going for 10 minutes it does
at least you should you should add that
feature that way if you know I mean it
doesn't record the future but it does
keep rolling for another like like 30
seconds
if I honk my horn right now it'll tell
us 10 minutes into the future for the
next five minutes the passenger is
scrubbing ahead you're gonna get cut off
in four minutes oh my God that's like a
scene out of out of there's still no
time to explain oh yeah yeah write that
down yeah yeah that's a good one for the
sequel yeah okay just to clarify like
what a Tesla does so there are there's a
bunch of cameras on a Tesla there's
three facing forward there's uh two on
both uh sides and then there's one in
the back that's like what it cameras
total but four of those cameras are
constantly recording to a thumb drive in
the glove compartment yeah at all times
and anytime you basically get into an
accident or you honk the horn or you
manually hit the button it'll
automatically record the last 5 10 30
minutes I think you can choose an option
for it uh and so that's why you're
always seeing a lot of dash cam footage
from Teslas yes they're just always
rolling yeah and run you much like a
pilot have a Tesla so okay you
approached me you have a lamb Chico or
Nick uh which they also have Teslas you
could have asked them yeah but you're
more you're fun you're a fun guy okay
I'll take it no they're all fine because
I got into a car accident in 2021 and
Mike Tesla was totaled yeah and then I
got dragged through the the mud on
Twitter for basically complaining that
my Tesla got totaled so I never so then
I ended up getting another one several
months later I tried to spend as much
time as I could without a car at all I
one will to work every single day for
like four months that got old after a
while yeah um but then I ended up
getting another Tesla and I never once
mentioned publicly that I did so well
never once said to anyone online that I
have a new one yeah yeah and you're like
I want you to do this I was like okay
all right here we go please uh and he
generously offered to uh drive all the
way up the mountains uh well that was
the other thing you're like I want it to
be like not in the city I want it to be
somewhere outside the city like out out
yeah out there there's no other people
who would be watching or fighting where
the truck is out there
this wasn't like really this was cut out
of the video too but like the idea the
angle behind that was like uh we wanted
like not only a unique perspective but a
location that kind of got more clicks
with something a little bit more
interesting and also made sense because
you know if you see a UFO a weird
phenomenon in a city there's a lot of
people in the city you know a lot of
witnesses so yeah we wanted to go to a
place full angles of that yeah yeah
exactly so we wanted a place that
justified it's its uh existence you know
something that was a little bit more
yeah so I'm I'm sitting there this is
like a Wednesday or something like that
and you're like hey I need you to drive
out into the middle of nowhere like ASAP
yeah yeah this weekend it's Friday this
weekend he's like oh yeah that'll be
great I'm like so you want me to drive
out in the middle of nowhere this
weekend yeah
and I was like okay I know it sucks but
you made a one-wheel trip I've made a
one-wheel trip out of it so it was great
uh me and a bunch of buddies we went up
to the top of the mountain
disappointment and one wheeled all the
way down to the bottom it was like a
five or six hour Journey it was great
yeah and then I got good I know you're
gonna ask why is it called Mount
disappointment it's called Mount
disappointment because they thought it
was the highest peak and then when they
actually measured it they found out it
wasn't so they renamed it
before it happens that's that's all it's
the same Mountain we filmed the Far Cry
Goat Simulator video on oh yes I love
that yeah that's a great one yeah which
is very very high up it's over a mile up
in the sky it's got a higher elevation
than disappointingly high yeah yeah
to leave something to be desired just
something I didn't feel like a game even
mountain high today yeah what was it
originally called I don't even know yeah
okay I mean it probably had many other
names by other people's but yeah yeah
but yeah so I was like all right if I'm
gonna go do this I might as well make a
trip out of it and it worked out so I
ended up having a blast and cool the
footage was an afterthought well so Ren
and all in all honesty though Ren it was
only you we couldn't get Sam or Nico
right or Nico or Nico and Nick Sam does
not we could get Nick Sam doesn't have
one right we couldn't get Nico because
Nico uh was someone we were trying to
fool on the debunking he couldn't really
know about out this oh my God I just
wait but you didn't fool him with that
video
with the new with the new one oh yeah
well I guess not the new one right
because Nico's gonna be on that trip
yeah yeah but he wasn't going to be like
super aware of like what we were trying
to do and you know the whole process I
don't know we just wanted to keep it a
little bit more you know low-key we were
revealing it to him and Sam at the end
yeah
because we got to completing this
footage with the Tesla that you captured
and then Jordan and Matt went to work on
then the plan became okay we're going to
bounce this off of samaniko to get their
reactions and thoughts on it yeah but
before we do that because they still
haven't seen the project Maple Leaf
footage and they still don't know about
it we're gonna introduce that
to them in an actual debunking scene so
it worked out perfectly because yeah the
justification was this
Jordan and Matt have made new UFO
footage UFOs are hot once again because
every few months there's some quote leak
well there was just a leak like a couple
of weeks ago and so they were talked
about once again so we said okay it's
time to do another debunking video and
Sam and Nico were like yeah that's great
idea it's timely let's do another one
and we're gonna do it follow it up with
this story and they were like great
makes perfect sense and then that was
the perfect opportunity to slip in the
old footage that they still hadn't seen
and that's right that's that's exactly
what we finally did and so we get to
debunking day and
Matt's downstairs
with Nick waiting to come up
now you're talking about like the
debunking video that I was playing today
yes and Ren we had told you about it at
that point we said we're gonna introduce
footage just pretend like it was
submitted To Us by it yeah yeah email or
whatever because I had already I was
already very well familiar with the
original like right infection for sure
yeah you watched music and stuff yeah
and all you know you were a man on the
inside someone had to kind of present
the footage test was whether or not not
only whether or not samanika would
believe it but whether or not they would
be able to pick out anything about it
yeah it took all of like five seconds of
Sam and Nico like staring intently and
Nico goes
yeah it's fake
it passed the first level of scrutiny
which was like you know the original I
couldn't see it the laughable test yeah
there's only been in the history of the
debunking series there's only been like
a handful
maybe five videos that have even passed
yeah Project Loon right Project Loon the
most infamous one and I think after
Project Loon this one probably is the
next one in terms of believability
that works for me I mean they said they
said it was the best one that they were
looking at yeah I don't know if that's
because they were saying it to my face
but yeah
yeah still though uh still you know it
was good to at least get some some of
their knowledge like Natty without that
extra layer of context for them you know
they thought they were just looking at a
video that was on the internet that had
no connection to us so that was super
helpful to kind of just get like a base
understanding of maybe what high level
VFX artists might think you know how
hard it is around here to keep certain
things quiet from other people for very
hard six months yeah it's super hard
yeah we spring a few leaks on the way
yeah
but as far as the footage you know the
Tesla footage of course there's a unique
perspective of multiple cameras which I
think kind of silences some of the
critics who might be questioning it
um but there's also the aspect of
performance and this is something I was
talking with Nick about in the very
beginning when we were all going to do
several videos is how do we get three
different perspectives but none of them
feature performance of seeing a UFO
because that is so hard to do do
naturally oh yeah I've seen you know
when they're debunking I've seen them
just dismiss stuff based on the audio
for sure like how run you just spotted a
UFO oh my God it is a UFO right well I
mean that was pretty crazy how did that
get up there I don't know are you
recording right now and then if you go
the other direction and you go too quiet
you're like oh whoa I wouldn't do that
no one's gonna believe that so so what
is a medium that strips all audio well
the Tesla cam yeah you're not gonna hear
any but you're gonna have the driver
going what the heck and just ruin your
whole day
yeah it was unique and it was silent it
was like a really nice what the heck
yeah the silence is key for sure yeah
because there's it's super hard to just
honestly like even if we did have some
footage that had audio recorded you just
wouldn't say anything that's the best
move is just don't say anything and even
breathing yeah it's not gonna end so you
made the shot you did the VFX on was it
two or three of the
or basically all three
um
then you posted it you posted it social
engineering comes into play it does it
yeah once does not simply just post
you know what's crazy you guys this is
great but y'all are getting a little bit
too far ahead because there's some other
stuff there's a couple of more details
here that I'd like to talk about okay
the metadata and the visual effects shot
as well okay so let's start with the
visual effects shot yeah right because
there was everything we considered the
camera tracking uh the the animation of
the UFO the compression the artifacts
you're just so excited you're on the
right page yeah that's exactly right
yeah you've skipped to pay a couple of
them
um yeah so basically there's all this
thought put into this VFX shot that
Jordan and I just kind of bounced off
each other on uh to just kind of get it
feeling believable but the the main
thing here and we didn't realize it till
pretty much we were like wrapping up the
shot and about to post it like this was
the day of that we were going to post
this this uh shot right uh these three
angles um and we had everything else
figured out and then we just took it we
took a step back and we looked at it one
more time and we went this doesn't feel
real so in there yeah just right even
though we we thought about everything
here and made it feel like it was
actually moving through the sky there
was something we were missing and indeed
that was the compression yeah it was oh
100 the compression uh because the Tesla
cams for all the technology and and
crazy nonsense that is in those cars
their their cameras are terrible look
they're kind of garbage they're pretty
bad the compression is nasty it is crazy
yeah so even with a DOT I mean like a
dot it was I think we measured it's like
50 pixels or something yeah even that
that felt like it was sitting just above
the compression yeah in such a way that
made it feel like it popped out and it
wasn't it wasn't a cohesive part of it
so when you zoom all the way in you see
this like the pixel the density doesn't
match you know the and there's also
there's all these compression artifacts
um and the the craziest thing actually
is that there was another object in the
sky that we didn't on we didn't know
what it was it's a UFO I'm usually I
think we might have actually posted
footage we might have actually caught a
real UFO in this shot and no one didn't
believe us there was a white orb that
was not moving in the sky it was not
flying and it was it seemed like it was
too big to be a star it wasn't moving so
it wasn't a bird so we literally don't
know what this thing is okay still still
I have no idea oh it's an airplane it's
not moving yeah it wasn't moving it
doesn't look like it's moving right
that's the power of Parallax I don't
know I will show it to you later no I've
already seen it I know what you're
talking about yeah yeah because you told
me that that's what you looked at for
reference for the compression okay well
don't ruin the mystery run that's the
fun of it isn't it I think it is
I think it's Venus part of a show where
we debunking stop debunking your Youth
Without debunking it's Venus or Serena
yeah Serena Williams it's one of those
Stars I don't know
that didn't make the cut either but he
really wanted to get that joke
yeah so anyway but hey why am I
mentioning this in fact this definite
UFO in the sky that we found for sure
it's a real UFO
um because it was the same color it was
the same like uh color values that we
had for our UFO it was a white object
right so we were like we can use this to
uh exactly match the compression the
kind of compression but then it's like a
matter of well how do you get the
compression you know this is what I'm
actually most curious about I have no
idea how you replicated the compression
look yeah well Jordan figured it out
frame by frame I painted each pixel
took the final comp everything together
and then batched it out as a JPEG
sequence at various levels of
compression going all the way dude have
you ever seen a zero quality jpeg
sequence
mind-blowing yeah it's just black and
white garbage it means nothing yeah so
we basically did like a sliding scale
all the way down and then I created like
a noise pattern that would let different
values through a different frames so
you're getting like this fluttering like
degradation and when it's closer to the
edge it's more garbage yeah because
that's what we were seeing in the
footage so it was a tool kind of built
like that using actual compressed jpeg
sequences and then matting it back in
yeah just where the orb was using the
alpha expanded Alpha yeah of yeah the
noise map did did you was it like the
regular noise map which has curves to it
which would cut off a compression block
with a curve no so is it a blocky noise
map well I I actually took batting it
back in I took the alpha of the uh
actual UFO thing which of course is
perfect and smooth and didn't look good
yeah but then I eroded negatively and
dilated essentially the matte out oh
okay and then feathered it in and that
was enough because it was in motion it's
pretty dramatic and you're still getting
the crazy blocky cubic in nature of it
all yeah but you're not seeing the hard
line that way so well that's fascinating
that's that's really cool yeah so it
gives you that Natty compression because
it is compression it's actual
compression you know it's it's how it
works it's how it works because we were
thinking like well do we you know how do
we get the effect right how compression
what is that Mosaic filter how do we
make it work no no just
yes
we tried MP4 because that's what the
file type is for the Tesla and we took
it all the way to the bottom quality
wise yeah for the exports and it made
really no impact so we went to jpeg our
beloved jpeg we knew we could crush the
heck out of it yeah and it worked yeah
my favorite flower Pig
so yeah at that point it truly is a pig
yeah at that
at that point we were like totally we
get we got it we have the shot this is
it final right but you know there's
still the matter of the metadata that's
a huge problem that we had to solve
because we knew that you know if I was
going to upload this in a similar
fashion present it in the same with the
same framing device that I used for the
original uh we were gonna get people
angry you know we were gonna get people
in the comments going yo this footage
sucks we need the original files right
so I I went and I uh did some research
Google search led me nowhere because uh
for some reason finding this deep rooted
metadata is a lot harder than you think
it's not just like there's an easy fix
for it or a plug-in or an app that does
it uh quickly it's it's uh it's an exif
uh data uh it's exif uh metadata uh so
it gives you like the history of the
file like where it's where it's been you
know it's all the dirty laundry comes
out and you just can't easily access it
through the Windows operating system so
you need uh there's a I I asked one of
our it guys because at the end of the
day I just couldn't find it on Google I
didn't know exactly what I was supposed
to be looking for you know I wasn't even
I didn't even know what the questions
were you asking me too and I was just
like yeah yeah because they're because
there's data in here that I didn't know
existed right so I was like trying to
find it and um one of our it guys Billy
uh great brilliant guy
um immediately pointed me in the
direction that I needed to go um he gave
me this executable uh where I could
actually pull up everything about the
file um and not not only that is I could
edit it there you go so I could copy and
paste the data of the original first
file with the math super secret super
legit yes yeah get rid of all that stuff
and paste in the the metadata of the
original Tesla cam so that you know
there when you and I did many tests
where it was like I dragged it back into
metadata data to go just to confirm that
there's nothing suspicious nothing funky
in there and there wasn't so because
nothing would be more devastating than
failing twice with via the same yeah
Avenue yeah this really was the Crux of
the video I know it's what I was most
nervous about I'm like yeah man if this
Falls to Pieces because of the same
reason that's hard to wrap up with a
nice little boat yeah you can't fail the
same way does the internet know that
that video is fake yet other than the
fact that we released the video on
Corridor today they will know tomorrow
when this podcast comes out yeah and but
we still haven't the post is still live
it's all still alive
that reminds me Matt you got to send me
the link to the post I did yeah I forgot
to put that in the description I did I
sent you both links I don't know if you
just want to use should I put those in
the description of the video yeah why
not
yeah yeah
so uh I want to ask questions about the
post but we're not there yet so you got
a final like well posting that you want
to make yeah but you're not gonna post
it are you no oh run you know you're
right I can't post it because my account
is burned to the ground the UFO
Community smells my BS right
I can't uh films Pro guide yeah dude
that guy does not admit do not that guy
is not legit something about the name
so yeah I was like okay so I gotta get a
some account that has no correlation
with me at all
um or or Corridor Digital or anything
like that and filmmaking
um so I got a A friend of mine from
Florida uh who's like in Florida and he
was an old-time friend like he goes all
the way back to like early High School
right so um and yeah so I we like we
play OverWatch together yeah yeah we
play video games together and like I was
like we were playing I was playing a
diva and we were just like uh I just
randomly threw out there like hey do you
have like a Reddit account and he's like
yeah I got one with like a it has a lot
of karma too it's got like a lot of you
know uh he's got like 8 000 something
like that so he's got you know he's
pretty Karma he's pretty active and that
definitely helps your posts too you're a
real person at that point yeah yeah you
feel like a real person and he's not
only is he a real person he's a tree
person
and you know those three people the tree
person he's a uh
I call them I call him a landscaper in
the video I believe or you did um but
he's a
horticulturistic ended it there
horticulturist yeah so it's a
culturalist horticulturalist you're
right so that's what you mean by tree
guy thank you thank you
um
thank you so much
anyway I clearly don't know what I'm
talking about which is good because that
means it's not connected at all to us
that's so far removed from anything that
we do or film in general right so it
worked right it was the perfect perfect
account to use right he followed a bunch
of tree accounts and stuff so he's like
a tree scientist
um anyway so yeah
when they dug into him they were like oh
that's the op's uh profile a little bit
he just seems like a regular Joe Shmo
that's right yeah I'm so glad we decided
to do that he loved that you know what I
told him they call him a joke
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so that totally
worked right so we had our we had the
angle
um the idea was that we would basically
get a step removed from the footage
itself
um and this is the same thing that we
did with the first post
um where it's you know it's my stepdad
sending me the footage of his cockpit in
the plane yeah heard it too yeah I know
that's great yeah inside of his plane
um and in the same sense it's this man's
hand I'm not going
it's this man in Florida's his aunt who
lives in California has a Tesla Florida
man yeah Florida man yeah so his aunt
from California with her Tesla sees this
UFO says that's crazy
Florida has an aunt in California
exactly it actually makes perfect sense
that is really the thing that happens
it's actually true uh but yeah so so
that was sort of the angle here was that
you know he was he was receiving this
footage from someone else uh so we're
step removed from any questions that
they they ask in the comments we can
just say like well I'll have to ask her
blah blah blah right if we need to
um yeah so that that definitely helps as
well
um helps a lot of things so basically
just having that backstory and like you
know just kind of not revealing
everything at once you know all that
stuff is super important for this
um to work so so then we posted it yes
we posted it post it yeah we were even
more probably definitely more nervous
than the first one
just casually posting and just see what
happens you know and then this time it
was like so much was built up to it and
so much more work had been done to
really make sure that it was gonna be
foolproof oh yeah yeah properly the
first time was like when you take a
firework that goes shooting off in the
sky and you just slide in your hand and
you throw it on the ground like what's
gonna happen and then it blows up and
you're like oh geez
okay now I'm actually gonna put it in
the tube and light it there sound like
you're speaking from experience right
yeah yeah you mess with fireworks yeah
um yeah so I may have privated a couple
videos on my YouTube channel back in the
day
oh my gallery rounds without a mortar
can yeah no I made a tutorial on how to
make a a sparkler bomb
and that was on YouTube for a few years
how do you make a sparkler bomb run
redacted
edit it out just like challenge jokes
I'll find a window for him baby yeah
they'll get in there
um okay so yes on Thursday everybody you
want to come down I got a place
to the jokes he's the guy no context I'm
just gonna say the words yeah it'll be
great I got a timeline just for you
buddy
uh okay so yeah so the post goes live
um it also like pops off pretty quick
yeah and that's cool like that's great
it's already a relief that it was like
starting to get going
um but we were like we needed that like
extra sauce to like push it over the
edge we needed that secondary account
yeah that could like do
because this one was even analysis this
one was even more subtle you know we we
posted like just the Natty raw footage
uh from the Tesla Cam and it was like so
hard to see the thing moving by that a
lot of people in the comments were super
mad and they were like hey yo like I
feel like it was easier to see than the
first one you did yeah the first one was
first one I didn't see it the first few
yeah yeah there was something about I
don't know man I think it was the fact
that I was zooming in like pinching and
zooming in that made people see it a
little bit more I don't know uh but that
didn't necessarily need uh an additional
account to fuel it um so yeah this one
was just a little bit more like well if
we want to really get it popping off
um let's let's use the XXX files XXX
um
it's time baby yeah because
because that account that account was so
active in the UFO Community right it
makes sense
Ally because
our trusted Ally from Canada our
Canadian Ally Professor Maple Leaf
that's why it's called that folks
because of the Canadian influence yeah I
see that yeah so wait when you say that
this account was active this is an
account that Fenner made just on the
side for this project that's what he
says but he's been using it yeah
I did all this for you
they've just been like actively
like that 2 000 posts
freaking it's an investment oh yeah you
guys said do this and I just figured I'd
do it yeah it's not weird don't get
weird
anyway that like so yeah so what I did
was I took the original footage and then
I doctored it I did like or not talked
to it but like I made it I gave it like
the extra sauce uh that the UFO
Community likes which is the red circles
the like extra crunchy instruments yeah
like just extra super contrasty stuff to
really see it yeah uh you know like just
showing every aspect of the thing that
we just and it was great because like
crunching it up actually made it look
more realistic yeah because because we
did the compression stuff you know if we
hadn't done that it wouldn't have worked
nearly as well well that's that was one
of the things that we did on the back
end before putting it out was just
testing it with all sorts of different
compressions and the entire lower gain
you know higher lower Gammas like
combinations of all the above and that's
when you really started to see it stand
out it's like people are definitely
gonna do this people are going to
download this basic question for me what
is gamma
gamma what is gamma I mean gamma I just
understand
that's actually a really good question
but gain is like the brights essentially
yeah if anyone in the comments knows
what gamma is no gamma's essentially
like your mid mid bias oh it's your mid
okay so if you have like your your gain
you know one or whatever and you're lift
at zero which is the blacks or whatever
okay your game your gamma is essentially
the bias as to like what is white and
black if that makes sense I don't know
if I'm butchering that but yeah it's
driving that so oh that's yeah you're
not playing around with that yeah you
could have said anything I would but I'm
like yeah yeah you know yeah
and I got hit with gamma rays and yeah
yeah it was like I got hit with a
mid-range of light that had some sort of
executive element to it you clearly you
understand the lift and the gain yeah
okay you clearly understand it cool yeah
this guy gets it thank you this guy
Gammas it up
but yeah so the compression helped in
those close-ups yeah for sure you know
the craziest thing about this in like
terms of like the social engineering
aspect of it and like what we had to do
mentally was like we had to put
ourselves in the shoes of everyone that
was looking at the video like the post
uh the the angle the spin that we put on
it um the back story all that stuff was
like well when we present it if I'm just
a guy on Reddit like what's the most
believable version of this like what at
every aspect like including having to
zoom in and look at the thing because
like if they were to download the
footage and see it let's really zoom in
like what would they find you know like
we had to think about all that stuff
yeah and it's so different than like
traditional VFX because obviously you
want it to look real and integrated and
that's great but people are gonna watch
it once at full speed and there's also
an idea of suspension of disbelief if
it's a creative piece and whatnot this
is like I'm trying to fool you they're
very good at suspension of disbelief
they want to believe yeah well I guess
that's kind of true but I was like this
one there's going to be someone who's
pausing it going frame by frame who's
zooming in who's applying filters like
testing every side of this thing yeah to
try and find a crack so we had to be as
thorough as possible yeah because I love
the detail that you made it more crunchy
the closer to the edge that it got
because that's an actual like yeah yeah
it's it's because it was real
compression you know yeah it was
actually doing that stuff so which is
great
um but yeah like so so you said they
want to believe right they do want to
believe but it's clearly like super hard
to like actually get them believing it
oh right okay because it is because it's
not it's not like as easy as just like
you know throwing uh VFX shot in there
we we saw like many posts where there
were clearly fake VFX and everybody
didn't believe no one was buying them
you know yeah it was completely
lambasted so like there was that extra
level of thought and care that went into
it because they're super critical you
know that's it's a super critical
community and it's people that uh they
really care about stuff that like
actually is unidentifiable you know like
without any cracking crevice right yeah
and that was is the constant battle
between how much you show versus how
much you hide and like even Matt was
working from home one of the days when I
was doing the animation of it throughout
the three cameras and I was losing my
mind because I'm like is this too weird
is it not weird enough and I watched it
too much that I became numb to it and I
had to wait till he came back it's like
oh no no no no
that's too much or that's too I can't
remember what it was but you know it's
like you're trying to put on this
critical thinking hat but you're the one
doing it and you're way too close to it
the whole time so you know very scary to
send it off into the world I think I
remember that it was a little too subtle
it was a little too subtle yeah it was
it was a little too hard here's my thing
that I want to ask you both about all of
this having gone through this
I mean what you've done here gentlemen
is you've created a true piece of
propaganda
yeah oh no oh yeah oh yeah you are the
Russia yeah please don't hire us
please don't contact us well you're
perfect for the general concerns about
you know Chinese or Russian Affiliates
you know sort of freaking out and asking
and saying hey no
honestly no because like because we do a
behind the scenes video right after so
yeah it's true
we only do a breakdown that shows them
exactly how to pull it off Russian
propagandists
more propaganda
and it says on the thing going oh
it was funny is we with the boss Town
Dynamics especially the military range
one he didn't intend that to be
like we made tried to make it very clear
that it was obviously fake especially
the more of it you watch but people took
it out of coffee out of context
immediately well we tried to add enough
absurdity that any amount of like logic
applied to is like yeah obviously this
isn't fake what I didn't expect how much
people would want to take it out of
context oh that's the one thing I didn't
expect and that's the one thing we
learned with that video like we thought
okay people may take this out of context
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
post it in one place we're gonna make it
absurd we're gonna make it very obvious
that it's not real yeah and we're gonna
make a video showing that it's not real
and then we're gonna put out another
video showing that it's not real and the
the E the eagerness to take it out of
context
was like that that was the thing I
learned about Humanity on that one yeah
yeah I'm not surprised at all I'm not
surprised at all have you felt any of
that yet or do you have any concern of
that at this point because I mean I
don't personally no yeah and I think at
the end of the day like if there's I'm
not trying to like get a message out at
the end of this necessarily but but if
you're if there's one takeaway from this
I think it should really be like this
stuff like footage like this it it's not
it is hard to fake it but it's not
impossible you know so you should not
believe everything you see on the
internet just just at face value you
know do your research do some digging
you know like you don't just spread all
this nonsense around and just you know
yeah yeah can I because there's so much
of it going around I would I would also
say that too like with our artist hat on
a little bit it's a fun it was a fun
challenge it's like can we fool people
who are looking for for fakery yeah and
I think we went in with three main goals
we wanted it to kind of pop off a little
bit and it got how many hundred thousand
uh like total combined it was like 300
views which is great like that
definitely passed what I was hoping for
personally also it seemed like nobody
sniffed the effect which was great like
everyone thought either bird drone
playing like all the other things yeah
except for visual effects which was
great yeah and of course perfect
illusion yeah that felt really good and
then of course it's the last piece which
is Matt Matt's Redemption Arc of putting
it on there with the metadata and no one
being able to drive anything from it so
those are the three check boxes that we
kind of had laid out in front of us and
we checked them off yeah and so it was a
personal challenge it was very rewarding
you know yeah apart from that I although
yeah it's I will say Matt I gave you
like what 20 or 30 minutes worth of
footage and I consider myself to be a
pretty good driver I'm a safe driver oh
no but there's a comment
I didn't see this you have thought about
this for weeks
thinking about this the whole time
please read what what did the comments
say so
I I cut the corner a little bit this is
on the road where we're going like 20
miles an hour and there's like a hundred
bicyclists coming up this thing so I'm
like going really slow and I went I cut
the corner a little bit on the sharp
corner and so you can see in the side
view camera view my tire goes over the
yellow line like a few inches before
going back in and there's a comment on
that Reddit thread that just started
tearing into your aunts about how bad of
a driver
it hurt me personally so much because
I'm like oh my God they're right
what have I become why did I do I was
like so upset I was not you pointed out
to me and I was not able to think about
anything else for the entire weekend
after it that was amazing I had no idea
yeah he's looking at footage of a UFO
and he's focused on the entire position
yeah right that's crazy oh that's
amazing
to me that that is that like epitomizes
Reddit and it's yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're trying to do this and then
somebody goes off about how somebody
went two inches over the yellow line on
a very curvy Mountain Road yeah I think
they were like a motorcyclist and that's
like a big pet peeve of motorcycles yes
people like cutting Corners yeah but
which I mean that's also I was like
let's do it too all the time oh my God
and like literally earlier that day I
almost got run over by a car like I'm
not even kidding like literally I almost
got run over by a car because they were
in like those like souped-up uh like
Japanese cars yeah oh yeah yeah and they
come ripping around this corner and I
remember looking up as far as I could
see there's no car and I look back this
way and I start crossing the road on my
one wheel because we're going on we're
actually filming Fast 11. that's right
yeah I felt like I was in the middle of
it not kidding and and like literally we
all had a moment of like that car missed
you by like a couple feet because I
managed to just like I tried to get off
the road as quick as I could I ended up
nose diving off of the road into a ditch
just in time for the car to come
drifting around the corner whoa was that
and that was on the trip that Matt made
you go on yeah yeah yeah
boy
and my nose just died I ended up just
doing like this nose drag off of the
road and just like into a ditch yay and
like my friends were there all just like
I thought you were gonna die wow like
that was a real thing that happened wow
and that was yeah that was and then
there's some punks that go up Angelus
Crest and ride it like that on the
weekends jeez man either way you're the
one that gets lambasted for this yeah
every weekend some there's every weekend
somebody gets hurt up there doing that
every week yeah yeah well but I didn't
get hurt and I'm here now thank God
thank God we're glad you're here hey it
was but I can't stop thinking about that
one comment yeah right yes
just disgracing your driving skills yeah
like
oh the footage is kind of like oh
whatever but screw that stupid Tesla
owner and they're awful driving and like
I was like whoa that's what it was it
was I didn't mean anything
else yeah the comments were great though
in those posts there's a wide variety of
them a lot of different uh angles on it
a lot of different thoughts uh so yeah
if you want to check those out I mean go
go watch the video on Corridor crew and
uh you know we got some links I'm gonna
do it as soon as I get home please do
yeah hell yeah brother I'm really glad
we did it uh thanks for taking the time
to explain it to everybody and yeah
really thanks for doing that Natty
compression Jordan really oh man it was
necessary it was
necessary wasn't it yeah
oh man all right that's actually a
really Pro tip for getting compression
yeah it's just compress it who would
have thought who would have thought just
compressed can you give us a song on
compression like Nico uh yeah him and I
always had this trick for like degrading
footage you basically had a tiny bit of
blur and then uh some sharpening a
little bit more blur a little bit more
sharpening a little bit more blur a
little bit more sharpening you can kind
of just do that like like we're talking
like a value of like one or two over and
over and over again and it like does
weird things to your footage but it
doesn't like do the compression yeah
yeah there's something very specific to
the look of it yeah that we just
couldn't get down any other way so but
I'm glad glad we arrived at that all
right are you ready
take us away
when your footage is low when your
footage wait let me start off I don't
know hey you guys have seen puncher
punch our new show head for head coming
soon that's exciting
I don't know what it's about but you
know visually interesting
[Music]
yeah
I don't know it's scary in the middle
it's gamma just compress it oh they
should play something cool they should
play this in colleges just go for
College film schools just compress it
look at this
there's like a compositing 101 of course
when your footages three two one